okay are you worried that this stuff
will be your legacy at the end of the
day
because it's it's you know i said this
leading up to the fight and
and and it was bothering me that people
were talking about you in a certain way
and
i tried to remind people hip surgery you
don't need me to defend your honor but
like oh my god but you know what i've
i've already said this to you ariel i've
we've already discussed this topic but
now that it's over
are you no no we discussed this later
legacy is stupid
legacy is something that people
shouldn't really be concerned about
um because you should just be worried
about what you're doing on a
day-to-day basis like moving forward
i'm going to keep trying to coach and
make kids and change the main lives as i
can and
and if i some will how long term achieve
something and people want to think back
on me favorably or unfavorably then
they're going to do that but you can't
determine what other people think
and you can't let what other people
think dictate your actions
and so i've already told you i i think
legacy is a relatively
stupid concept um from from a self
perspective like i'm going to do this
because of my legacy
i think that's that's a really negative
thing for people to actually think about
um so i try not to think about it ever
for myself
so you but you don't sit back and say
like man you know when i'm 60
is this going to be the first line or is
this going to be the foot ever
ever ever that's good because you
shouldn't
you really shouldn't it's it's
counterproductive to your current life
to think about
what people what people may think of you
in your future life
and just like literally do do what you
want to do in your
in your current life and if it fits your
morals and standards
and if you can stand by it then stand by
it and if you think you should be doing
other things then go do other things
and that's it but um to think of what is
someone going to think of me in 30 years
that's counterproductive
and so you have won way more in your
life than you have lost
however and i hope you take this right
away you're one of the best
losers that i've ever met in the sense
that no one ha you handle defeat
and and you you don't just lose you have
lost twice in a very
you know public and spectacular way and
you had to look better than anyone who
taught you
how to do that because it's such a uh
i mean so i would just say the thing
that taught me to
never ever be um i mean i think i think
my dad was probably a big influence of
like not being scared just go
go freaking do you know um but the other
thing i think that was probably a big
influence
i wasn't good i wasn't good in the
beginning so it's just like i'm just
gonna go compete as much as i can
if i lose i lose and then i'm you know
i'll just keep moving from there
and then i probably i probably should
credit a little bit to the fact that i'm
slightly autistic i think that's like
allows me to just like be in the moment
with whatever i'm doing right now